He's called "the Mozart of chess" and I can see it.
You couldn't understand how Mozart did what he did, it came from another world.
And Magnus Carlsen is doing things that no human being I've met before can do.
At one point, he played ten chess players at the same time, looking the other way...
...so he couldn't see the boards.
I mean, just think about it: ten chessboards that he has in his mind every second,...
...doesn't lose track of what's happening on the boards...
...and what he needs to do next.
Can you explain what was going on in your head?
Really, I was just focusing on trying to remember the positions...
...and from time to time, I had to think a little bit...
...to come up with a good move as well.
Even he admits that it's not easy.
I would wonder where a certain piece is...
...and so I have to replay the game in my head from the very beginning.
How long does it take you to do that?
I don't know.
Just half a minute or something?
It will be interesting to try like, 20 people sometime.
Have you ever done that?
No.
Ten is the most I've done.
And, but you'd like to try more?
It would be fun.